there are more than a hundred and forty
thousand patient admissions to the
hospitals of the public health service
every year
our patients include american seamen
like ships carpenter danny callahan who
received care at the boston hospital
officers and enlisted men of the u.s
coast guard
coast and geodetic survey
other uniformed services and their
dependents
american indians alaskan natives
federal prisoners and other groups
designated by the congress
we also provide medical education for
interns residents medical students and
many others in our hospitals
the first responsibility of our
hospitals is the health of our patients
the second responsibility is medical
education
medical research is one of the most
important factors in providing the best
patient care
and the best medical education
today several of our hospitals are
conducting research in association with
medical schools and other institutions
for example
the public health service hospital in
new orleans
has developed a comprehensive research
and training program in cooperation with
the medical school at tulane university
one of the people who recently played a
major role in this program is dr john l
wilson
former medical officer in charge at new
orleans and who is now retired from the
service
through the enterprise of dr wilson this
building on the hospital grounds was
converted into a research facility the
siemens memorial laboratory
the director of research at new orleans
is dr john jay walch who received his
research training at tulane
i've asked dr walsh and his colleagues
to give us a brief report on their
program
we could define
the research activities in the public
health service hospitals
as directed
towards one objective
that of better patient care
with the inevitable accompaniment a
better professional training
and better professional status
it has been our philosophy to have a
diversified program not dependent upon
one man
nor upon one discipline
currently we have approximately
four thousand square feet of laboratory
space and 31
full-time people working in our research
laboratory it has been our feeling that
these full-time academicians and
full-time investigators
should be available to the hospital for
teaching and consultative purposes
and also
to help to create the atmosphere of
intellectual stimulation
and curiosity so necessary
if we would make a hospital a teaching
institution and not a trade school
in which merely techniques are learned
briefly
our overall program
is as follows
there is a tropical medical section
which is an integral component of the
department of tropical medicine and
public health at tulane
work in this area is primarily concerned
with natural and acquired resistance to
parasitic infections
in the second
of our three major sections
research
endeavors
are oriented towards the surgical field
this project is concerned currently with
the application
of regional profusion to the treatment
of malignancies
the third
major area of investigation
which concerns our laboratory is that
concerned with cardiovascular diseases
and specifically
with studies of the dilated heart
the research on the dilated heart at new
orleans is under the personal direction
of dr walsh and dr george e burch
professor and chairman of the department
of medicine at tulane
dr burch is known around the world for
his research in heart disease
as we know one of the great problems in
cardiology is the problem of a large
heart most patients who die of heart
disease either die because of congestive
heart failure which is as a rule
associated with a large dilated heart
are from coronary disease with a
myocardial ischemia
our main interest is to
try to first define as well as we can
what a large heart is
we attempting to approach this both from
the
anatomical point of view not the
necessarily just gross anatomy but from
the point of view of detailed
microscopic studies as well as from the
point of view of electron microscopy in
addition a chemical definition will be
attempted
trying to define
the
inorganic chemical state of the dilated
heart as well as certain aspects of
organic
chemical changes
in addition to that an effort is being
made to treat the
dilated heart particularly in patients
who have so-called intractable failure
where efforts have been made to use
the usual conventional therapeutic
procedures and still the patient seems
to go downhill
one of the ideas that has been proving
to be of considerable success is the
idea of long bed rest patients have been
placed in bed for periods varying from
six months to a year or even more and so
far this has been proving to be of
considerable value to these patients who
would have been dead if it were not for
this period of rest unfortunately this
does take a great deal of time
in order to see through enough patients
to have an idea as to what the
statistical significance of all this is
but even with a few number of patients
we
know so far that this has a great deal
to offer at the moment
research at the new orleans hospital
includes several disciplines one of
these is biochemistry
here is dr joseph arkas associate
professor of biochemistry at tulane to
explain the work being done in this
field
the program of the biochemistry section
centers on the study of alterations in
endoplasmic cellular membranes
the same techniques are applied to
investigate these alterations during the
process of heart dilatation
and during chemical carcinogenesis in
the liver
at the present time we are studying the
mitochondrial membrane by following
changes in the swelling ability and
shape of this cell particle
the first slide shows a phase of the
procedure for isolation of mitochondria
all these operations involving living
tissues are carried out at near zero
degrees centigrade in the courtroom
incidentally the young man pictured here
is a second year medical student at
tulane university school of medicine
who is receiving research orientation
while conducting a summer research
product project at the u.s public health
hospital research laboratory
the second slide shows members of our
group injecting into the guinea pig
desoxycorticosterone which produces
heart dilatation following thrones
administration
the third slide shows the measuring by
photometry of the pattern of
mitochondrial swelling the investigator
pictured here is a science student from
formosa taking part in the research
trainee program of tulane university
medical school
the fourth slide illustrates an
extension of this approach that is to
study changes in the shape of the
mitochondria such as elongation
shortening or curving
such alterations are determined by
following the particularly symmetry by
light scattering at various wavelengths
finally the last slide shows a phase of
another research orientation of our
program
here changes produced by various
chemical agents in the macromolecular
science structure of proteins are
studied by following in a polarimeter
the optical rotation of the solutions
in this way we hope to obtain
information on the mechanism of drug
action at the basic macromolecular level
although prolonged bed rest is a basic
therapy in the treatment of the patients
participating in the dilated heart
studies at new orleans drug therapy is
also important
the pharmacology studies are under the
direction of dr thomas d darby associate
professor of pharmacology at tulane
investigations with intact hearts and
with hearts in situ are now in progress
in our laboratories
in this slide
a
isolated heart is demonstrated
a
anderson isolated heart perfusion
apparatus is used in combination with a
bubble type oxygenator and sigma motor
pump system
in these studies
the coronary arteries are perfused with
oxygenated blood obtained from donor
animals
the purpose of these experiments is to
determine the direct effects of a drug
or a combination of drugs on the force
of contraction of heart muscle
in the next slide
an experiment is being carried out with
the heart in situ
in this study
direct measurements of the drugs on the
force of contraction of the heart are
good being compared with hemodynamic
parameters
in this study a total body perfusion is
carried out blood is removed from the
right atrium of the dog and returned to
the left atrium of the dog in this way
the right ventricle and lungs are
bypassed the blood is oxygenated in a
bubble type oxygenator and pumped back
to a reservoir which returns the blood
to the left atrium
measurements of isometric contractility
isotonic contractility
and our force velocity curves can be
obtained from the non-working ventricle
these measurements are compared with
isometric tension in the working
ventricle
in addition to the biochemical
physiological and pharmacological
studies clinical studies of drug effects
are also in progress
one of the medical residents is largely
engaged in the clinical studies and
takes part in the laboratory experiments
the residents are an important part of
our applied research program
they are daily in contact with
therapeutic problems
and are willing to work to obtain the
answers
the training in our laboratories is also
multi-discipline in addition to the
public health service personnel there
are two graduate students in
pharmacology from tulane university and
two medical students from lsu receiving
training here
a total of 30 patients have taken part
in the dilated heart studies at new
orleans and 20 of these have now been
discharged
here is x-ray taken of the heart of mrs
irma francis when she was admitted to
the hospital as a special study patient
for this research program
here is a heart as it is today
and here are the two x-rays side by side
dr walsh visited mrs francis and
interviewed her where she is now
employed
irma i think our listeners might like to
know where you're working would you mind
telling us please i work at chalmette
laundry one of the largest laundry in
the city of new orleans
uh irma
what kind of symptoms were you having
before you went into the new orleans
public health service hospital
i was having severe pain
in the chest
between the busts you know and the
stomach down here
and uh i was very slow and full of
fluid
and uh my feet and legs and everything
had swollen and i had vomiting spill
and you had had heart trouble for some
time before that hadn't you remember i
had i found that i had an in-law heart
since 1937.
[Music]
from 1958 i had trouble
trouble on and off in and out of the
hospital
until november around november
1958
i was entered in charity and then from
charity i went to public health hospital
and for about six months
to nine months i didn't do anything but
rest
then after that i began to uh go down go
to the bathroom and walk around
until i was discharged
in august 1959.
now
since you've gotten out of the hospital
irma have you had any trouble with your
heart i haven't had any trouble i've
been feeling fine and i work every day
you see the kind of work that i'm doing
and uh how hot is it in here right now
it's really hot right now but it doesn't
bother me i understand it's 109 right
now
here's another photo of mrs francis
taken recently at the new orleans
hospital she still takes a great deal of
interest in the heart project and
returns nearly every week to help with
the care of
patients one of the resident physicians
now working on the cancer project is dr
james n winblad a resident in surgery
dr winblad began his research in cancer
perfusion
if you would ask me if i would want to
go down to lane and spend a year in
relative isolation working on a basic
research program that perhaps had no
direct clinical bearing or no direct
clinical relationship i would have been
relatively uninterested
but what happened was that we were able
to work on a relatively basic problem
that is the development of
of techniques
for isolation profusion of extremities
and other regions of the body and then
apply this to the treatment of human
cancer in a relatively short time that
is in a span of a relatively few months
we developed the techniques in dogs for
extracorporeal circulation and regional
perfusion and then applied it in the
treatment of human patients with cancer
the present medical officer in charge at
new orleans is dr johnny troutman who
has served at several public health
service hospitals and was formerly
director of the clinical center in
bethesda maryland
i considered
that research over the years in our
hospitals
was one of the best recruiting devices
that we could possibly have and i
believe that if the service is to go
forward and to attract
proper
personnel
career people to carry on the work of
the service
that the service
will have to
develop its research facilities in our
hospitals
to the utmost
we are leaders in the field of medicine
not only
in the united states but in the world
it behooves us
in the service
to have the best possible research
facilities
the best possible hospitals
to accomplish the aims which every good
clinical facility should have
when we began organizing this present
research program at our new orleans
hospital we were fortunate to have the
fullest possible cooperation and
encouragement from one of the nation's
leaders in medical education dr maxwell
lapham dean of tulane medical school
the close affiliation of the u.s public
service hospital with the school of
medicine of tulane university has many
important facets
in the first place it unifies two
institutions
uh which are dedicated to medical
training and medical care
it allows for the interchange of staff
and facilities specifically the
facilities of the public health service
hospital are of tremendous help to the
school of medicine
here because our students and faculty
can work with the different kinds of
patients from far-flung areas and also
learn more about the objectives and
responsibilities
of the public health service hospitals
moreover the hospital staff members who
have medical school appointments have
assisted greatly in our teaching
programs
on the side of the hospital staff
there is opportunity to work with men
who are dedicated not only to medical
training and medical service but to
pursuing basic and clinical research
many of the hospital staff members find
a deep satisfaction in pursuing a more
or less academic career within the
framework of their public health service
responsibilities
this should be of assistance in
recruiting people in the into careers in
the health service throughout the
country
they will have the satisfaction of
knowing that in addition to rendering
superior medical care
they are contributing to medical
knowledge through research within both
institutions
the public health service is indebted to
dean lapham to dr george burch and to
other members of the tulane medical
school for their generous cooperation
their enthusiasm and encouragement in
helping us to carry forward the research
program at new orleans
in addition to new orleans we are
conducting research in other public
health service hospitals
in the indian health program and in the
hospitals in the federal prisons
one of the most important types of
research we are now conducting
is the inner hospital project where
several public health service hospitals
joined together
on a common problem with a single
protocol
here is the public health service
hospital at staten island which served
as administrative center for the first
inner hospital project
seven hospitals are now conducting
investigations in the clinical
pharmacology of various drugs designed
for the treatment of essential
hypertension
these inter-hospital investigations will
help to speed up the testing of new
drugs
our baltimore hospital pioneered heart
research in the service in cooperation
with the national heart institute and
also has an important program in cancer
chemotherapy in cooperation with the
national cancer institute
our seattle hospital and the medical
school of the university of washington
are setting up a cooperative research
program
our san francisco hospital is working
out details for research in association
with a major medical center and with a
medical school
research in the indian hospitals is
developed around the clinical health
problems of the indians for example at
the present time pilot studies are being
planned or conducted on diabetes anemia
cervical cancer nutrition tacoma otitis
media and diseases of the gallbladder
since 1930 the public health service has
had responsibility for directing the
medical program of the bureau of prisons
in the department of justice which
maintains 22 hospitals
for several years we have conducted
research projects in many fields of
investigation with the aid of volunteer
prisoner patients
it is aim of the public health service
to develop these research activities in
our hospitals in order to provide our
patients with the best possible medical
care and to enhance the quality of the
medical education research also provides
the opportunity for physicians and
others in the service to extend the
range of their skills and to add greater
depth to their professional judgment
it is essential that we make these
opportunities available because our
ultimate success in fulfilling our
responsibilities for the health of the
nation depends directly upon the skill
the wisdom and the dedication of the men
and women in the public health service
you